[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages
heute mit riesig freut mich sehr schönen
guten abend ihnen allen alles was
wichtig ist in den nächsten 20 minuten
corona bleibt ein schwerpunkt und den
sport den gibt's heute wieder mit
kristin otto und ein novum guten abend
wir blicken jetzt auf die themen des
tages
neuinfektionen steigen intensivstationen
am limit gesundheitsminister sparen
forderten massive kontakt reduzierungen
die mehrheit in deutschland meint die
politik zur zu wenig gegen korona
neue virusvariante erreicht europa
experten zeigen sich besorgt über eine
krone mutation aus südafrika
und schweres heimspiel für die bayern
bosse auf der jahreshauptversammlung
gibt es pfiffe und buhrufe wegen des
sponsorings aus katar
die vierte corona welle produziert
weiter höchstwerte außerdem bereitet
weltweit eine mutierte virus variante
neue sorgen eine mehrheit in deutschland
wünscht sich strengere maßnahmen der
politik und die streitet gerade über
eine vorgezogene bund länder runde
während es immer lautere rufe nach
deutlichen kontakt einschränkungen gibt
müssen deutschlandweit dutzende
intensivpatienten verlegt werden schauen
wir erst einmal auf die zahlen die das
land so sehr unter druck setzen jeden
tag sind es mehr 76 1414 neuinfektionen
meldet das rk ii das sind gut
23.000 mehr als vergangenen freitag und
eine trendwende ist nicht in sicht
innerhalb von 24 stunden sind 357
todesfälle hinzugekommen die sieben tage
incidents liegt jetzt bei 438 co2 wie
sehr das die verantwortlichen alarmiert
das zeigt uns jetzt winnie heescher
schwerst erkrankt und dann verlegt
werden sechs intensivpatienten werden
ausgeflogen von der luftwaffe von bayern
ins münsterland im süden gibt es keine
freien intensivbetten mehr in jedem
fünften intensiv bett in deutschland
liegt ein code patient es gibt nur frei
intensiv aber diese freien betten werden
dadurch erkauft
das in den belasteten regionen zb
geplante operationen verschoben werden
oder ausgesetzt werden zb
tumor-operation
oder transplantationen das heißt andere
patienten bekommen ihre behandlung nicht
mehr und eine neue sorge kommt hinzu
eine weitere variante des corona virus
zuerst entdeckt in südafrika wir sind
sehr besorgt und ich hoffe sehr dass
stringent dahingehend gearbeitet wird
dass zumindest die ausbreitung dieser
variante so gut wie möglich durch
reisebeschränkungen eingeschränkt wird
der lka-chef und der gesundheitsminister
fordern beide deutliche kontakt
beschränkungen gern sparen kritisiert
auch dass die ministerpräsidenten nicht
früher zusammenkommen wollen alles was
wir jetzt nicht entscheiden alles was
wir jetzt nicht reduzieren an kontakten
wird in zwei oder vier wochen im zweifel
noch drastischere maßnahmen notwendig
machen und das glaube ich muss man im
moment verstehen und müssen auch alle
verstehen deswegen kann man eben nicht
auch zehn tage noch warten und gucken
aber in dieser frage sind die
ministerpräsidenten so weit auseinander
wie die instanzen spitzenreiter heute
der erzgebirgskreis mit einer sieben
tage incidents von über 2000 andere
regionen wie zum beispiel hamburg stehen
besser da da guter impfquote und 2g
regeln schon im sommer andere länder
haben leider da darauf verzichtet und
haben über freiheitsrechte nachgedacht
und sind jetzt in einer situation wo wir
alle wieder gemeinsam ein problem haben
der vorwurf geht gegen bayern zu spät
mögliche maßnahmen ergriffen zu haben
politik im schwarze peter modus wir
brauchen eine schnellere mpk wir
brauchen eine schnellere entscheidung
wir brauchen eine entsprechende
notbremse
die verlegung von kranken in andere
regionen ist eine lösung aber auch sie
ist begrenzt
also die pandemie lage wird immer
bedrohlicher theo koll in berlin
geschäftsführende und designierte
bundesregierung sind sich uneins und die
ministerpräsidenten im grunde auch was
folgt daraus
ich befürchte daraus dürfte ein weiterer
vertrauensverlust in die kompetenz von
politik folgen während die einen eine
vorgezogene ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
fordern gilt ja für die anderen mann
könnte überhaupt erst in ein bis zwei
wochen beurteilen was die neuen
maßnahmen gebracht hätten politisch hat
sich die ampel koalition völlig unnötig
in eine extrem heikle lage gebracht mit
einem gesetz das allgemeine ausgangs
beschränkung und flächendeckende
schließung nicht mehr zulässt haben sie
sich politisch verwundbar gemacht es
stimmt einzelne länder könnten auch
schon jetzt deutlich mehr und schärfere
maßnahmen ergreifen aber die sich
zuspitzende lage fällt dennoch der neuen
koalition auf die füße denn noch ist
unklar ob der maßnahmenkatalog des neuen
gesetzes reicht und während des wartens
auf die ergebnisse spitzt sich die lage
weiter zu am kommenden dienstag
verkündet das bundesverfassungsgericht
sein urteil zur bundes notbremse sollte
die für rechtens erklärt werden dann
öffnet das vielleicht auch politisch die
tür für weitere und für schärfere
einschränkung dann vielen dank nach
berlin theo koll ja wie die politik aus
der sicht der bürgerinnen und bürger in
der kroner krise agiert unter anderem
dazu gibt es frische zahlen im
zdf-politbarometer und einige wollen wir
jetzt mit matthias fornoff aufgreifen
hallo matthias die wir werben wie
bewerten die befragten die ergriffenen
maßnahmen in der pandemie na ja es wird
nicht genug getan das sagen knapp zwei
drittel der deutschen entsprechend sinkt
die zustimmung zu den geltenden
maßnahmen 15 prozent finden sie
übertrieben 30 prozent gerade richtig
eine mehrheit von 52 prozent aber findet
die maßnahmen müssten härter ausfallen
das gilt auch für die in letzter zeit so
viel diskutierte allgemeine impfpflicht
69 prozent sind dafür 29 prozent dagegen
im juli waren noch 64 prozent gegen eine
impfpflicht
die stimmung hat sich also komplett
gedreht matthias zuletzt wurde der druck
auf ungeimpfte ja immer weiter erhöht
wie kommt das denn dann ja auch da sehen
wir ein sehr klares meinungsbild
76 prozent der befragten finden starke
einschränkungen für ungeimpfte richtig
22 prozent nicht gegen solche
einschränkungen für ungeimpfte sind
mehrheitlich nur die anhänger der afd
grundsätzlich positiv werden die
maßnahmen im neuen
infektionsschutzgesetz gesehen das ist
keine bundesweiten schließungen mehr
geben soll finden 58 prozent gut und die
3g regel am arbeitsplatz befürworten
sogar 83 prozent
corona wird als das überragend wichtige
thema gesehen ganz anders als noch vor
vier wochen dann fielen dann kommentiert
ausführlich können sie das
zdf-politbarometer ab 22 uhr 10 im heute
journal sehen oder jederzeit online in
unserer zdf heute app außerdem gibt es
ein zdf spezial zur krone krise um 19.20
also direkt nach unserer heute sendung
ja großer sorgen also wegen der vielen
corona infizierten und dann wir haben es
ja eben schon mal angesprochen auch noch
das in südafrika ist eine virusvariante
entdeckt worden die viele länder
alarmiert das veränderte corona virus
b115 29 weist mehrere bisher unbekannte
mutationen auf und ist möglicherweise
ansteckender als die gerade grassierende
delta variante die bundesregierung hat
deshalb den flugverkehr aus südafrika
eingeschränkt und schärfere
einreisebestimmungen erlassen christoph
gäste zum stand der dinge
flughafen johannesburg noch gehen von
hier ausflüge in die welt reist die neue
variante mit fieberthermometer und test
soll helfen sie aufzuhalten derweil
versuchen forscher b115 29
schnellstmöglich auf die schliche zu
kommen wollen wissen wie viel gefahr in
den mutationen steckt noch kann das
niemand sagen ein indiz gibt es aber
innerhalb weniger tage ist die anzahl
der täglichen corona fälle in südafrika
von 200 auf über 2.000 geschossen
wahrscheinlich wegen der neuen variante
europa zumindest ist gewarnt testet hier
am flughafen amsterdam ganz genau wer
aus südafrika kommt und mehrere
europäische länder haben bereits ein
reisebeschränkungen verhängt auch
deutschland gültig ab heute nacht
das bedeutet dass eine einreise oder
eine beförderung die fluggesellschaft
nach deutschland du noch für deutsche
möglich ist und diese müssen ob geimpft
genesen oder nicht für 14 tage in
quarantäne
noch weiter geht die eu-kommission
schlägt allen mitgliedern vor den
flugverkehr mit der krisenregion vorerst
völlig auszusetzen trotz der dünnen
datenlage zur neuen variante wobei
zumindest eins als sicher gilt noch nie
ist das corona virus an so vielen
stellen gleichzeitig notiert vor allem
haben so wichtigen staffel über den sich
der erreger zugang zum menschlichen
körper verschafft damit könnte er
leichter eindringen würde also
ansteckender zweite gefahr möglicher
weise erkennt selbst das immunsystem von
geimpften den mutierten stachel kaum
noch aus sie würden sich also leichter
infizieren könnte ihr impfschutz sogar
ganz weg brechen eher unwahrscheinlich
heißt es wir sind gut geschützt durch
eine impfung werden wir den
vollständigen impfschutz haben und ich
gehe davon aus dass es auch durch diese
neue variante dass wir einen weiteren
impfstoff haben werden paion tag
zumindest will schnell prüfen wie sein
impfstoff sich gegen die neue variante
schlägt es könnte eilig sein in belgien
ist b115 29 wenn auch nur mit einem
bestätigten fall heute schon angekommen
ja und soeben hat die whu die neue virus
mutation als besorgniserregende
eingestuft sie wird nach dem
griechischen buchstaben omikron benannt
wir blicken noch einmal genauer auf die
lage auf den intensivstationen die sich
immer weiter füllen kliniken und
pflegepersonal kommt zunehmend ans ende
ihrer kräfte
freie betten gibt es zwar noch insgesamt
fast 2300 aber der großteil ist
bundesweit belegt nämlich
19.800 72 betten in rund jedem fünften
liegt ein komapatient verena garrett
jetzt über einen der viele wochen dort
verbracht hat
mit der linken hand kann er sein handy
bedienen in seiner rechten sind die
nerven geschädigt folgen von sechs
wochen intensivstation
47 tage wurde giulia diana beatmet ende
september hatte er sich mit kohl wird
angesteckt er ist 30 jahre alt geimpft
war er nicht
relativ viel im internet
halt auch passiert
das alles fehlinformation ist schön zum
trost halt stimmt das alles gar nicht
und sie haben geglaubt 3 schocks leider
trotzdem geglaubt warum
weil ich wie gesagt ich war mir relativ
sicher sage ich das selber netz bekommen
wie er ist ein großteil der kurve
patienten die auf die intensivstation im
klinikum saarbrücken kommen nicht
geimpft noch haben sie kapazitäten
schwer erkrankte aus anderen
bundesländern zu versorgen dieser mann
kommt aus baden württemberg sein zustand
ist stabil
der behandelnde arzt findet drastische
worte mein kollege
kriegsähnliche zustände
und die haben es heute dort irgendwie
sechs patienten exportiert war
gesprochen erinnerungen an die zeit auf
der intensivstation hat giulio diana
nicht er sei kann im skeptiker heute
würde er vieles anders machen das denkt
man darüber nach hätte ich mich bloß
impfen lasse also das habe ich mir
wirklich gedacht ist mir zunehmend
schlecht dagegen er kann doch nicht
sitzen nicht stehen nicht essen wann und
über hauptschule diana in zukunft wieder
in seinem beruf als industriemechaniker
arbeiten wird was zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
niemand
es wird deutlich mehr getestet in
deutschland wegen der immer weiter
steigenden infektionszahlen und fällt
ein erster test positiv aus folgt darauf
in der regel ja ein pcr test und nach
den neuesten krone bestimmungen müssen
sich ja auch ungeimpfte testen lassen
bevor sie zur arbeit gehen die folge
test und laborkapazitäten werden immer
knapper peter theißen war im rhein main
gebiet unterwegs
lange schlangen vor testzentren sie
gehören mittlerweile zum alltagsbild
deutscher städte die gründe fürs testen
vielfältig machen schnell den muss ich
machen wollen bekannter kroner positives
ich habe den kontakt und ich habe morgen
einen op deswegen musste ich jetzt das
schnell erledigen keine welt keine
arbeit war sich sicher gäbe ich bin
schon drei mal und wird dort natürlich
nur testen und so erreicht das testen in
deutschland mittlerweile rekordniveau
alleine 1,8 millionen pcr tests pro
woche so viele wie nie zuvor wir
arbeiten jetzt wieder deutlich mehr an
wochenenden in einigen laboren auf 24
stunden sieben unsere mitarbeitenden
sind wirklich sehr belastet und wir
helfen uns mit den laboren auch wenn die
kapazität nicht ausreichend und geben
dann proben auch an andere labore sowie
dass die krankenhäuser mit den patienten
auch machen denn die auslastung ist
regional sehr unterschiedlich während es
in hessen noch kapazitäten in den
laboren gibt sind das saarland und
sachsen schon weit im roten bereich
mancherorts dauert es bis zu 48 stunden
bis das ergebnis da ist um die ständig
wachsende menge an test zu bewältigen
arbeitet dieses labor in der nähe von
frankfurt rund um die uhr auch am
wochenende das personal wird knapp die
zahl steigen deutlich an unserer letzten
monat haben proben zuwachs von 100 500
prozent eng wird es mittlerweile auch
bei vielen apotheken diese in wiesbaden
führt um die 60 schnelltests durch pro
stunde die selbst führt zu hause sind
auch schon ausverkauft seit gestern und
wir hoffen dass sie in den nächsten zwei
wochen wieder da sind engpässe also bei
material und personal dabei soll das
testen doch ein wichtiger baustein sein
bei der bekämpfung der pandemie
viele tests die gehören ja auch zum
alltag der schulen schließlich sollen
sie trotz wachsender corona probleme
unbedingt offen bleiben so das
versprechen aller landesregierungen
zumindest in sachsen ist das aber immer
schwerer zu halten manuela conrad seit
dienstag ist die grundschule johanna in
dresden geschlossen zu viele corona
fälle bei lehrern und schülern das virus
macht nicht halt vor sächsischen schulen
hier an der 117 grundschule in dresden
müssen sie jeden tag improvisieren heute
haben sie hier das erste mal seit wochen
keinen positiven corona fall noch ist
die schule geöffnet aber es könnte jeden
tag schluss sein wir bereiten uns quasi
auf den lock down vor jetzt üben mehr
wie sie ihr aufgaben abrufen können und
emails schreiben können dass sie gut
vorbereitet in die zeit geben können
verunsicherung bei schülern und eltern
sorge bei den lehrern und vom
gesundheitsamt komme schon lange nichts
mehr beklagt die schulleiterin wenn man
die ganz offiziellen meldewege ein held
weil dann wartet man vergeblich auf eine
rückmeldung die landesregierung hält
trotz der schwierigen situation an
schulen weiter an präsenzunterricht fest
wir tun alles dafür dass das gelingen
kann im moment ist ja auch die
rechtslage ganz klar so dass eine
flächendeckende schulschließung nicht
möglich ist
mittlerweile sind aber
121 schulen in sachsen geschlossen jede
vierte ist von corona betroffen und
infektionszahlen steigen weiter wenn man
nicht politisch entscheidet zu schließen
dann entscheidet irgendwas virus die
schulen zu schließen die vierte welle
trifft sachsen mit wucht die
landesregierung hält inzwischen einen
kompletten lockdown vor weihnachten
nicht für ausgeschlossen
die grünen haben ihre urabstimmung über
den ampel koalitionsvertrag gestartet
allerdings einen tag später als geplant
weil erst gestern am späten abend wurde
man sich über die verteilung der fünf
ministerien einig als vize kanzler und
minister für wirtschaft und klima ist ko
parteichef habe gesetzt genauso
co-chefin berbalk als außenministerin
der frühere grünen-vorsitzende özdemir
soll landwirtschaftsminister werden die
ehemalige bundesgeschäftsführerin lemke
ist für das umweltministerium vorgesehen
und familienministerin soll eine spiegel
werden bisher umweltministerin in
rheinland pfalz
einen tag nach dem schweren
grubenunglück in sibirien sind 46
bergleute für tot erklärt worden
außerdem starben fünf einsatzkräfte bei
den rettungsarbeiten
ein verschütteter helfer konnte sich aus
den trümmern befreien dutzende menschen
werden wegen gasvergiftungen noch in
krankenhäusern behandelt gestern hat es
eine schwere explosion unter tage
gegeben als wahrscheinlicher auslöser
gilt methan die staatsanwaltschaft
ermittelt wegen möglicher
sicherheitsverstöße der bergwerks leiter
wurde festgenommen
normalerweise heile welt beim fc bayern
münchen aber dann kam die
jahresversammlung was war das ersten
abend arg turbulent pfiffe und buhrufe
tumultartige szenen unterm strich war
die für mitgliederversammlung des
rekordmeisters ein desaster viele fans
des fc bayern münchen reagieren mit wut
und unverständnis auf den bestehenden
deal mit katar
keine halbe stunde rum und erstmals wird
es ungemütlich für bayern präsident
heiner
[Applaus]
die kritik ist groß am millionenschweren
sponsoring durch den umstrittenen wm
ausrichter katar doch zu einer
abstimmung über die beendigung des katar
deals kommt es gar nicht ich werde hier
nicht zulassen dass wir rechtswidrige
über rechtswidrige anträge abstimmen ob
ihnen das bieten
sie betonen immer wieder wie wichtig der
dialog ist aber sie schaffen es nicht
einmal mit den eigenen mitgliedern und
mit menschenrechtsorganisationen einen
konstruktiven dialog zu kommen der
cutter streit köchelt auch nach dieser
lebhaften hauptversammlung
weitere corona fälle in der bundesliga
rb leipzig der als einziger
erstligaverein zu hause ohne zuschauer
spielen muss fehlen am sonntag gegen
leverkusen neben trainer marge und
torhüter gulasch vier weitere spieler
die positiv getestet wurden darunter
willi orban fünfter sieg im fünften wm
qualifikationsspiel für die
nationalmannschaft der frauen auch ohne
spielmacherin dzsenifer marozsán gelang
dem team von bundestrainerin maria voss
tecklenburg in braunschweig gegen die
türkei ein wahres vorsichtige 18.03
pfeffer allein durch die überragende
lehrer schüler und noch zum wintersport
mit einem novum endete der zweite
weltcup im skeleton auf dem podest in
innsbruck drei männer alle zeitgleich
ein sieger trio
das hat es noch nicht gegeben spannender
geht's kaum drei erste plätze auf die
hundertstelsekunde genau zwei mal platz
eins also das war jetzt schon echt der
hammer der deutsche skeleton weltmeister
christopher roth er legt im zweiten
durchgang vor dann der chinese language
an wüst seinen vorsprung ein ist so
zeitgleich mit er und auch der führende
nach lauf eins der brite matt westen
vergibt sechs hundertstelsekunden und
wird erster allein gut er aber übernimmt
die führung im gesamtweltcup
und jede menge wintersport morgen hier
bei uns von 11 uhr an wir zweimal auch
gleich zeitgleich fast feierabend und
kurz vor dem ersten advent kommt jetzt
passend der schnee hat ja erklärt dann
gleich wo es überall weiß wird das heute
journal mit claus kleber sehen sie um 22
uhr 10 und hier geht es jetzt weiter mit
dem zdf spezial wir sagen danke fürs
zuschauen entspannten freitagabend und
gerne bis morgen um 7
[Musik]
genannt heute kam der schnee von zwei
seiten zu uns zum einen hier aussieht
osteuropa und zum anderen vom nordwesten
und diese schneewolken die beschäftigen
uns auch jetzt in der nacht jetzt
aktuell schneit es ja im westen aber
auch am alpenrand und im laufe des
morgigen tages ziehen die schneewolken
weiter nach südosten aber auch in
norddeutschland reicht es hier und da
für eine kleine weiße überraschung
machen sie sich also auf gefährlich
glatte straßen und gehwege gefasst in
der westhälfte da fällt regen
schneeregen und schnee oberhalb von drei
bis vierhundert meter im osten bleibt es
dagegen trocken bleibt kann es dort
allerdings auch sein denn die
temperaturen dieser nacht sinken auf
plus 3 bis minus 4 grad und morgen
bleibt es kalt die höchstwerte liegen
zwischen 1 und 5 grad und es wird immer
wieder regen schneeregen oder auch
schnee am längsten schneiders wohl am
alpenrand im westen werden sie hin und
wieder auch mal kurz die sonne sehen am
freundlichsten aber wird es hier
zwischen der uckermark und dem thüringer
wald am sonntag wird es noch eine spur
kühler mit höchsttemperaturen zwischen
minus ein und plus vier grad es gibt
weitere schneeschauer und so kann es
dann am sonntagabend in den bergen für
fünf bis 40 cm neuschnee reichen aber
auch in norddeutschland gibt es weiße
flecken guten abend